that's right another week of game
releases yes unfortunately you get me
this week because Mary is getting her
wisdom teeth pulled ouchies let's get
right to it then first up arslan the
warriors of legend is the second video
game based on the novel series the
heroic legend of our Celyn and it pulls
its visual style and characters from the
2015 TV animated series this hack and
slash action-filled game lets you
command a Calvary and plow through enemy
lines or you can say screw the horse and
take them all on arslan the warriors of
legend comes out on the 9th first
through was China then there was India
now it's Russia assassin's creed
chronicles russia may be the third and
final installment of the series but this
time around it shakes things up a bit
this title changes the formula
stylistically by being set on 2.5
deplane and using a propaganda art style
play as nikolai in his attempt to
survive the aftermath of the october
revolution by leaving from
trans-siberian trains and getting
personal with a bayonet you can either
buy this standalone episode or the whole
assassin's creed chronicles trilogy
februari ninth zombies they're coming
dying lights first expansion the
following releases on the 9th as well
what can you expect from this expansion
let's see here brand new map in the
outback and what better way to explore
this map then with your trusty dirt
buggies which are fully customizable
tack on details paint job weapons and
attachments to better show off to your
buddies new story new characters new
ways of killing zombies what is fire
watch it's a first-person adventure game
taking place in the Wyoming wilderness
in the aftermath of the Yellowstone
fires of 1988 you play as the fire
lookout volunteer Henry where you
explore the shoe show National Forest
searching for clues and unraveling
mysterious events such as who left the
light on in the tower
remember to prevent forest fires on the
9th also this 9th brings the final
installment of the fighting game series
naruto ultimate ninja yes the ruto
shippuden ultimate ninja storm 4 will be
the first title of the series built for
the current-gen consoles new features
include the ability to swap characters
during battle and the ability to break
weapons and armor incorporating
elemental damage meaning if your clothes
are on fire they can burn off he's cute
he's cuddly and he's only made out of
one string of yarn get out of here yes
that's right be puzzle-platformer
unravel rolls out this week follow yarn
ease journey using his yarn to swing
form bridges and solve puzzles all the
while using just that one insanely long
piece of string follow the thread on the
ninth there you have it those were just
some of the bigger releases of the week
you can check out gamespot com for the
full list release states are based on
retailer listings and our subject to
change thanks for watching